and I'll tell you this um oh hey hey
Internet I'm sick and tired and when my
voice get steep you know I'm dead
serious
yes I'm sick and tired are you guys
suggesting I'm old rate
Frank's tart tartness and [ __ ] look at
the dents and lines in his face some of
the comments
there still are so funny people are just
so ruthlessly old this is why my dad
shouldn't have a smartphone dude but it
wouldn't ever I post a picture with you
it's just oh man y'all chill at a dog
town I don't even dad bro sweet Pig I
don't read the comments but now I read
them to see how mean they can be and
it's just you got a head like an
insurance salesman you [ __ ] [ __ ]
just watch us what wrestling excuse me
sorry dumb question
no one doesn't it chin I hear be honest
I'm surprised you don't watch pro quiet
rest I don't know I'm surprised feel
like it might be a little bit of your
flame hole know as a kid baby yeah yes a
kid I did I'm all set it must be a blast
to do although it's physically showed to
me I think it's a blast Kurt Angle
tonight he had more injuries from from
pro wrestling by far than wrestling yeah
yeah well I was never like jumping off
[ __ ] laughs yeah yeah yeah I find it
that I respect what they do and I know
it's hard I find it so embarrassing when
I watch it when I cap the wrist off oh
oh I'm like oh dude that guy's 4d acting
like that but the best is the guy who
uses his dong what he helped put your
hand on his dong and he flips you you've
seen it what in the Derby deadline what
yeah he's got ya with you have dick that
dong powers of like have you not seen
this awesome guy he's the greatest of
all time not really he's a famous
wrestler crotch yeah he throws you
what's his name
WT Razak riders cross zack ryder is that
rider Zack Ryder I don't know well yeah
I'm not mad at her no nor should you be
this is a Q&A dude the WWE Diva girls
are hot enough to make yeah there is
there is
in fact he throws dudes he phase but
just have put Jax matter throwing dudes
with his crotch if this is his move I'm
sure we should put yeah whatever his
name is throwing dudes especially dick
it's his move it's gonna pop up yeah
he's a stud and this is real yeah be
able to see this is really no this is
real dudes are you sure it's that writer
I don't know it's just it's all just
malarkey in it it just all says you but
I think a lot of it's true
it's so strange I don't know the guys
name is he's awesome now Cain Cain
Velasquez is doing it enjoying it good
for him Naoko becoming 10 wants to
eventually get into it
jail this is a lot of guys a lot of
money well yes mess with it I don't
there's not a lot of money again it's
like the UFC only the top guys are
making money if you talk to any of you
guys even the real famous ones I do did
until you get to a certain level you're
not making a comment actually it's just
like for that for ya if I thought about
right there on the road 300 days a year
like you're not you're not scrooge
mcduck rich unless you're the rock or
Batista or like a different level and
you know even the rock now in his movies
has to be Dwayne Johnson cuz dub W owns
the name the rock oh yeah yeah they get
a certain percentage whatever uses the
rock rock what would your name be if you
were I know a mine would be ground Bay
Brown what if you couldn't use big brown
I got I gotta get some royalties on that
kind of wet my beak yeah you don't how
do you beat you've been a little rink
have you little rank yeah you you're the
rinks rinks I'm rank rank rank easy
wrinkle wrinkles dual just wrinkles but
then the crowd yells ranked ranks
wrinkles and dense wrinkles and dense
wrinkles and dense no just wrinkles now
um but I feel like I'm also small so I'd
have to have baby in there or no no no
you're not you're not a real wrestler
you're like you're like the the guy
who's like oh yes my precious yeah yeah
Undertaker
yeah the Paul Bearer you're my Paul
beare I am big brown and rings I don't
like this you know be in a suit whatever
you just hear how I just yell weird [ __ ]
from the France
Brian you [ __ ] sued come on like in
an alternate universe you know all the
wrong choices yeah give me a second man
okay I'm I can't afford [ __ ] blow so
I'm snorting adderall you can imagine
how what a life that is like Penn &
Teller which one doesn't talk is it
teller you think I hate this [ __ ]
life like he's just like oh I can do
this again yeah but Dad don't talk to
the mother
yeah that's your gimmick right that's
your all the time when you have a when
you have a gimmick that you have to
stick with yeah when you have a routine
then yeah that's your schtick they used
to call it a David Spade and I weren't
talking for a while I don't know what
happened I just said a joke about him at
Phoenix or whatever and then and I swear
to God Adam Sandler wrote it he didn't
get credit for writing it cuz of other
people rewrote it or whatever but he
made Benchwarmers and hired the two of
us so we'd have to work together for two
months and work it out and we did and we
wouldn't friends ever since
oh cool so but like they're just a
stupid [ __ ] that you go through when
you're in your late 30s whatever I'm but
his choice you get all they just don't
care yeah just like what am i warhead
matter you know remember and I like it
but yeah I remember like one two on that
movie there was a guy I was quite
talking like that like a [ __ ] thick
Boston accent and one [ __ ] yeah you
know this guy is [ __ ] guy you know
and I just walked over and I said okay I
didn't know it was an actor I know he's
a comedian probably but I said okay what
nice thing did you do to Adam Sandler
when he was 19 that bet he remembered
you for and put you on this movie and he
said let me tell you [ __ ] what
there's a [ __ ] bowling alley and we
were [ __ ] working this young [ __ ]
kid Adam Sandler and I said look pal you
got a [ __ ] you know just get your
five minutes together and make sure that
[ __ ] kills and then you [ __ ] get
that like Lenny Bruce Larkin who is that
Monica me but it basically like the same
yeah and you [ __ ] put that together
and then next thing you know you're
getting your [ __ ] together and you're
[ __ ] you action before you start
doing your 20 kick a [ __ ] five pow
great that's about as good as Southie as
I've heard and you and Adam met on
Saturday life no we were we were a comic
friends I was like he was like a young
like 19 or 20 year old New York cop
I heard of him and then I got on David
Letterman when I was really young what I
really didn't have Rob did you start in
North alley oh that's where he started
like a if you don't move out of there
early it's over to her you got to send
that Tim today I said that they're their
dues if when I was in New York yeah I
saw guys hanging around the comic Club
and I go I'm never going you're gonna be
here forever
I gotta get the [ __ ] out here see the
pit you know it's like hey it's like
they've got their fans and it's working
it's comfortable to get a nice place
they can either one of the guys one
night one of those lifers looked at me
like this like you're in jail he he
waved he was waving in the direction of
what he thought was that way anything
goes you you you got positive energy go
to LA go to hell I said get out of here
forgot like Cobb's and punchline is that
were absolutely I just mind that all the
best guys came through there but you
learn from them like and Jerry
Seinfeld's warning on one of the
greatest and like he would come by and
he would like tell us well hey you guys
you gotta click on swearing out what
take the swearing out what said yeah you
take the swearing out if it's not funny
without the swearing but it's not funny
yeah so take it out and see if it works
you can't do that on TV this is like
1984 you know and then you see guys in
like you know Jay Leno would come by and
he was the nicest guy and I remember
like it was a manager who I had was
actually a heroin addict at the time
great guy he's still alive thank God he
got over - but like he said you go pick
him up you take him you pick up make
sure you're there on time this before
like we had before the internet before
ways we had Thomas gasps Thomas guy
Thomas guy baby and they say you had to
know where you're going luckily I knew
San Francisco's like a street rat so I
knew my way around
she said just make sure make sure you
take him to his radio show make sure you
take him to the gig make sure you are
there on the airport what was the Jim
Bob's no no no no he was at that time he
was doing like anyway he was on
Letterman going wait what's your beef J
hey became my beef you don't need to
attend you might be and that was his
thing and he started selling out
he went from clubs to like theaters so I
was picking when I drove him around and
he said and finally about halfway
through the thing you wanna get some
lunch meaning you don't need to Chinese
much I said I know the best mr. Leno and
so I took him to the place that like you
know my dad wouldn't even take me it was
too expensive but he said my dad used to
go that place is expensive
eight over here just as good you'll see
kids anyway so you said come on you I
hate my life come on eat with me you
mean so throw your comedian they said
yes sir how much time you got
I said I got about maybe eight minutes
they said good I'm glad to hear that
most people most comedians ask how much
time again I got two hours and I get
three hours in who wants to hear two
hours of comedy material either have
twenties all you need and be in LA 20
minutes become a star you don't have
that you don't have anything just get
five minutes that kills if you don't
have that you don't have anything if you
don't find me the kills every time
everywhere you go every time then you
don't have anything so I said just work
on your five minutes so that was like
that grace advising already never told
me yeah these are thank you so I just
instead what I said I said some no
Robert
nobody gave you a roadmap of how to be
successful in comedy so I just worked on
the next six minutes I work in that and
NICTA work on that one and eighteen
months later I perform that same bit on
on the Letterman Show I didn't have much
more than that did you move out here Rob
after that after the first yet literally
the next day I moved to LA so it's gonna
be a really high quality I love where do
you do most your reps that Rob you know
what believe it or not like I like I
love do it working in LA and it really
is the Comedy Store is the most
important comedy club in the world the
one right here and you know what they
just never had enough money in the old
days to ruin it
yeah you know you know you weren't like
you know there's like a club is like
this Columbus it was like improv it was
great you know it's a kind of a
restaurant it wasn't that great I mean
the room didn't look that great but it
was perfect the energy in there it's not
we fixed it we got a real Club and it
ain't as good
yeah everyone well that never happened
to the store stays the same the stores
been like a dumpy dive and that's what
you need you need the audience to hide
and it's perfect so it's a great place
if you can get it out of your own head
that they're that they're not judging
you the try stuff and like it's
interesting you see the greatest comics
in the world to go up there and it's a
little in their head that they're being
judged it's a little bit right well you
don't like a lot of comics do new
material there yeah some of them do
right Rogan BER will go up.this when you
spot a lot it that's what you're
supposed to do but a lot of guys
especially if it's like Tuesday night
where it's killers like the other night
when it was freakin Jeselnik Joey Diaz
Theo von oh yeah before them and do all
new material while they're doing hitters
no tough man well the thing is you can
do like the greatest things when I got
you know who talked me into doing it
truthfully talking about games do when I
was doing grown-ups which in 2009 and
Chris Rock said you know you got to get
back
do it man and I said well you're the
best at it not know I'm never gonna be
as good as you said he said no nice he
said you could be the best at this you
could just you could be you know and you
just got to do it I don't know what I
talked about just talking about he
talking to me every day life just the
way he would approach things what he
would talk about and the way he would he
would come at it from a new angle
he's mirrorless and I've seen him write
full house right on stage he came up on
stage with me like I was letting afraid
for that song he's a guy who would do
all-new [ __ ] he came up right after the
Boston bombing okay I was on stage
performing I was talking about any we're
at Rob how was that upstate it was in
New York like Nyack or something like
that there's a nice Club up there yeah
and all of a sudden it's this guy like
you know because they're always looking
trying to figure out what's happening
you think of the next thing you thinking
of okay they dig that one physically
what am I gonna do next you know it's
late and then I'll sit at the corner my
I see somebody's walking on the stage
from the left side and I said who is
what you know and like it's this guy
gonna stab me this guy gonna attack me
this guy you're gonna is this that is
this the bouncers there a fire all the
stuff that goes through your head when
there's somebody walking on the stage
who you can't really see and it was
Chris Rock coming on stage and I just
said oh my goodness when crazy and I
just handed him the mic and he just is
right after and he did that joke about
like you know the Boston bombing you
know where they they put the bomb at the
end at the finish line can you imagine
and I go where's he going they said they
imagine that you run 26 miles and then
somebody else run and I was like oh my
greatest genius and this guy and then he
did like another 10 minutes and like the
thing about it and I remember because at
the same time because I got back into
doing this in social media so like you
know the [ __ ] that like you can get from
whatever if you make a mistake of a
tweet of a joke whatever and I just
remember calling him because he was got
so much [ __ ] off doing this one routine
on Saturday Night Live and I called him
and I said dude I said like that was a
hilarious joke and I said I can't
believe it anybody would have a problem
with that and he just said [ __ ] oh yeah
he's the best okay get sec what are you
looking at that [ __ ] is the same thing
like Louie Gohmert said that's me you
can say anything you want it's it's it's
eight people on Twitter welcome yeah
while talking to you why wouldn't I give
that to you as it's a guess it's a gift
it's a gift